[Music]
I'm Keith Olbermann and this is the
resistance boycott the inauguration it's
very simple don't go don't watch don't
tweet don't respond don't spend money on
it don't spend one brain cell on it
depend upon this if the Bible leaps from
his touch or the authorities arrest him
for violating the Logan Act you will
hear about it I'm headed for Los Angeles
to be on Bill Maher show inauguration
night we will give you the info and if
you are an elected democratic official
under no circumstances attend I don't
want to hear about you working with him
unless you're working with him to move
to the Caymans I want to hear about your
plans to impeach him or force him to
resign an exception is offered to
President Obama although later sir I
think you will regret having had
anything to do with this man I believe
in forgiveness Congressman John Lewis
said I believe in trying to work with
people it's going to be hard it's going
to be very difficult I don't see this
president-elect as a legitimate
president I think the Russians
participated in helping get this man
elected and they helped destroy the
candidacy of Hillary Clinton I don't
plan to attend the inauguration you
cannot be at home with something that
you feel is wrong I think there was a
conspiracy on the part of the Russians
and others to help him get elected
that's not right that's not fair that's
not the open democratic process correct
to John Lewis one of my heroes wrote
Nebraska senator Ben Sasse please come
to the inauguration it isn't about a man
it is a celebration of peaceful transfer
of power [ __ ]
if you think senator that handing over
this country to the puppet of Vladimir
Putin should be celebrated and should be
a peaceful transfer of power you are not
only not loyal to this country but you
know nothing about John Lewis if you
think senator that we will let you or
anybody else normalize the transfer of
power to a racist seemingly psychotic
Russian plant perhaps you should look
again at how heroes like John Lewis
responded the last time the white
supremacists of this country insisted
this was about power and that we must
all accept its use and its misuse
peacefully John Lewis once did very
noble things tweeted the
editor of The Wall Street Journal's
weekend review but that shouldn't give
him a pass for poor judgment now irony
poor judgment a Wall Street Journal
idiot invokes knowingly or not the
language of apartheid John Lewis we
shouldn't give him a pass of course it
could be worse something like that could
have been said by an elected official
John Lewis ought a look at history it
was Abraham Lincoln that freed the
slaves
it was Rutherford B Hayes and ulysses s
grant that fought against Jim Crow laws
a simple thank you would suffice
governor paul lepage of maine [ __ ] who
among other things has invoked President
Rutherford B Hayes without any apparent
recognition that Hayes became president
in 1877 after an electoral college
disaster that required a compromise that
included assuring in the Jim Crow laws
in the south and then of course
Congressman John Lewis should spend more
time on fixing and helping his district
which is in horrible shape and falling
apart not to mention crime-infested
rather than falsely complaining about
the election results all talk talk talk
no action or results sad that's right a
hero who in the 60s literally put his
skull where his mouth was was attacked
by a clown who on a daily basis puts his
foot where his mouth is if you ever
needed evidence that Trump not just some
of his followers not just some of his
nominees evidence that Trump was himself
personally always and unchangeably
racist and in tune with true white
supremacy he just confessed to it
they're too racist scum like Trump
because Luis is african-american his
district must be in horrible shape and
falling apart
in fact Lewis's district contains
Georgia Tech Emory University the
busiest airport in the world the Centers
for Disease Control and parts of the
wealthy nearly 80% white suburb of
Buckhead which likes to style itself as
the Beverly Hills of the east what a
stupid weak man Trump really is bluntly
these tweets were written by a pig
boycott this pigs inauguration actually
that's not fair
pigs are supposedly as intelligence as
three-year-olds whilst in all this is
that the true operative part of John
Lewis's remarks are not his words about
the Russian conspiracy the Russian
conspiracy is obvious
to everybody from this nation's true
patriotic conservatives and Republicans
to this nation's intelligence
infrastructure to everybody but this
crazy man Trump and his gullible
supporters even the smarter ones who are
coming out of their trance and according
to the polls are beginning to understand
that he has already fleeced them but
that's not the key right this minute nor
is the key what congressman Lewis said
about Trump's legitimacy he is an
illegitimate president his name will
someday appear with an asterisk Court
will be wiped from our history
altogether but know this sentence is the
key you cannot be at home with something
that you feel is wrong there's your rule
thank you again John Lewis you do not
open your door to the man the thought
the action that you know is wrong and
you don't go to his home to his speech
to his parade happily this message is
getting across see this this is the
Gallup poll on how Americans of all
shapes sizes and parties are reacting to
how Trump is handling the transition and
congratulations Russia he's now
officially in the red fifty one percent
disapproval up from forty eight percent
disapproval the months before at this
time in 2009 Obama some of whose
opponents believe he was the Antichrist
was at a disapproval rate of twelve
percent and Trump got two majority
disapproval because of the so-called
independence who put us into this
nightmare in the first place in December
forty six percent of independents
approved Trump's handling of the
transition now thirty three percent a
quarter of his support among
independents gone in a month they have
been seeing something with new eyes that
the rest of us either concluded months
or years ago or were standing too close
to see they looked at this snot-nosed
Punk at the news conference with the
props and the terrified woman from the
winner of the Russian law firm of the
Year award and they looked at those
gratuitous stupid raving tweets about
John Lewis on the weekend before Martin
Luther King jr. Day and maybe they saw a
full-fledged racist and maybe they
didn't and maybe they saw a psychopath
and maybe they didn't and maybe they saw
a Russian mole and maybe they didn't but
you know what they did not see they did
not see a president boycott the
inauguration
resist peace